mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour une catastrophe s'est déroulée
ce matin à 20 divers guides l'efs oui
nous aurions aimé comme hier commencer
ce journal par des images du championnat
du monde de ski à val gardena où
l'autrichien karl schranz a remporté ce
matin le slalom géant malheureusement
s'il nous faut parler de montagne ce
n'est pas de sport mais d'un drame qu'il
s'agit aujourd'hui à 8h en effet ce
matin à 8h à val d'isère -une à valence
s'est abattue sur un chalet hôtel de
l'union des centres de plein air et aux
dernières nouvelles il y aurait une
quarantaine de morts nous allons appeler
tout de suite à lyon renault lafarge de
notre station régionale pour qu'il nous
donne tous les détails renault lafargue
courants sont maintenant les opérations
de dégagement bien effectivement vous
avez dit tout à l'heure 40 morts c'est
le dernier bilan et ce n'est qu'un bilan
provisoire de cette avalanche qui a
envoûté vous le disiez un chalet de
l'ucp à val d'isère une avalanche de
poudreuse venant selon toute
vraisemblance des hauteurs de solaise
venant selon toute vraisemblance donc de
ses auteurs de soles venaient s'y
engouffrer large de 50 à 100 mètres
large de 50 à 100 mètres à l'aller
s'infiltrer par toutes les ouvertures
contrairement aux avalanches de neige
dure qui bute contre les parois ses
parois de secours elle existait en fait
en amont de l'hôtel bien entendu les
secours ont aussitôt été mise en place
mais il était contrariée par les
mauvaises conditions météorologiques
à 10h le plan orsec était engagée par le
préfet de la savoie
pour l'instant il est toujours
impossible hélicoptère d'atterrir à val
d'isère et la route bourg saint maurice
val d'isère fermé aux particuliers
toujours dangereuses en raison des
risques d'avalanche qui persistent seuls
les ambulances peuvent les emprunter
on annonça la station qui ne sera pas
possible de chiffrer avec exactitude le
nombre des victimes
avant ce soir car les sauveteurs doivent
effectuer de nombreux sondages et l'on
peut redire on peut redouter d'autres
pas qu'avant d'arriver sur les immeubles
l'avalanche s'est emporté de nombreuses
victimes sur la route de l'iseran de
nombreuses voitures dans les faits été
emportés on ne sait pour l'instant si
elle était occupée une légère
amélioration des conditions climatiques
est attendue pour cet après midi elle
permettrait dans ce cas
l'évacuation par hélicoptère des blessés
mais les risques d'avalanche persiste
surtout le versant ouest
on a eu très peur ce matin encore à
chamonix
ou une nouvelle avalanche s'est
déclenchée entre argentière et le col
des montets elle a semé la panique parmi
les habitants
mais heureusement cette fois elle n'a
fait ni victime ni dégâts matériels à
tignes qui a aussi beaucoup souffert ces
derniers jours la neige tombe sans
discontinuer et les routes sont toujours
bloqués bien entendu nous tenons au
courant de la situation heure par heure
et nos équipe de grenoble qui effectue
un reportage à tignes seront à val
d'isère dès que la route sera dégagée
sans doute ce soir aurons-nous des
images de cette tragédie
et puis en dernières nouvelles une
nouvelle que nous donne notre station de
grenoble un premier hélicoptère
l'hélicoptère de la protection civile a
réussi à se poser à 12h30 contre les
éléments déchaînés et cela à 150 mètres
du lieu de la catastrophe
voilà c'est tout ce que nous savons pour
l'instant oui je crois qu'il faut
préciser tout de même que nous ne
connaissons rien encore en ce qui
concerne l'identité des victimes mais il
y avait environ 200 jeunes gens dans ce
chalet de l'ucp à dont une vingtaine de
belges six jeunes allemands et tous les
autres étant des français naturellement
si nous avons d'autres nouvelles avant
la fin de ce journal nous vous les
donner il faut préciser aussi que c'est
un communiqué qui m'arrive à l'instant
que monsieur georges pompidou s'est
personnellement ému de cette catastrophe
et il a demandé à monsieur raymond
marcellin le ministre de l'intérieur de
se rendre immédiatement à val d'isère
pour constater ce qui se passe et aider
les sauveteurs dans leurs efforts
le mauvais temps la pluie continue aussi
de provoquer des inondations dans la
moitié nord de la france à paris la voie
sur berge rive gauche a été rouverte ce
matin mais dans l'est les rivières
continuent de déborder comme en
témoignent ces images de notre station
régionale de dijon en côte d'or
aujourd'hui la saône amorcé une légère
baisse dégageant les routes nationales
83 et 396 jusque-là inondée à aussonne
les postes de garde et canaux 2d fermé
et ailleurs la navigation est très
ralentie dans la région de verdun sur le
doubs la côte d'alerté a été dépassé de
1 m 52 lots menacé de franchir les
digues
on a dû se résoudre à lever les vannes
pour éviter des dégâts aux ouvrages qui
de toute façon n'aurait pas empêché
l'envahissement de l'eau bref la rivière
a quitté son lit inondé les pré
avoisinant si les bêtes après si peu on
cite le cas d'une vache que l'inde lui
c'était la mule du pape au premier étage
d'une ferme
les pêcheurs eux saisissent l'occasion
et plein d'espoir tentent leur chance
on craint cependant une remontée
possible d eau dans les prochaines 48
heures si les précipitations sont
toujours aussi abondante la faculté de
droit de la rue d'assas à paris est
fermée depuis ce matin c'est le résultat
des bagarres qui ont opposé hier durant
presque tout l'après midi des gauchistes
à des étudiants d'extrême droite à la
suite de ces incidents le doyen bar ra
pire les faits la décision de fermer la
faculté pour la journée en fait depuis
quinze jours la situation était tendue
les étudiants extrémistes faisait la loi
dans le hall hier il a suffi d'une
affiche arraché pour déclencher une
bagarre entre gauchistes et étudiant
d'extrême droite
à 18h15 la situation s'aggrave en
certains étudiants s'étaient armés de
matraques et de pieds de chaise
le doyen faisait alors appel à la police
qui délogeait extrémistes des deux bords
à 20 heures tout rentrait dans l'ordre
bilan deux assistants blessés ils
voulaient séparer les protagonistes
selon l'administration il y aurait 30
mille francs de dégâts
après les incidents de nanterre les
bagarres d'assas de nip le riz
l'accalmie aura été de courte durée dans
l'université
elle aura duré dix jours exactement dix
jours après les affrontements de
nanterre et d'assas cela recommence
c'est presque toujours le même processus
on discute on se traite de fasciste on
se traite de bol chaud le ton monte et
c'est la bagarre mais audelà de ces
bagarres ce qui est important c'est de
voir l'université livré aux étudiants
gauchistes et d'extrême droite certains
certaines facultés sont devenus le
meilleur terrain des luttes politiques
entre extrémistes rentre et il termine
par je voudrais ajouter que cette
escalade devient extrêmement dangereuse
car certains étudiants parlent
maintenant de constituer des groupes
armés d'autodéfense je pense que c'est
très très inquiétant où cette inquiétude
se traduit d'ailleurs dans diverses
réactions politiques enregistrés hier et
ce matin l'union des jeunes pour le
progrès les jeunes gaullistes accuse les
mouvements de gauche de vouloir semer
l'anarchie dans l'université
le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste monsieur alain savary qui
revêtent certes une part de
responsabilité sur le gouvernement
mans n'en condamne pas moins le
comportement de ce qu'il appelle des
éléments irresponsables et le ps eut
lui-même déclare qu'il désapprouve les
groupes révolutionnaires qui font de la
provocation au ministère de l'éducation
nationale on se contente de dire la
politique universitaire n'a aucun
rapport
dans ces affrontements entre gauchistes
et sai mouk ces gauchistes ou ces
extrémismes de tous bords ne bloqueront
pas l'application de la loi
universitaire de la loi d'orientation
universitaire dans les affaires
internationales il faut surtout retenir
la fin hier soir du petit sommet arabe
qui s'est tenue au caire un communiqué
violent l'a conclu c'est une attaque en
règle contre les états unis
les chefs d'état arabes menace de s'en
prendre aux intérêts pétroliers
américains au moyen-orient
dans le même temps monsieur yasser
arafat le leader de l'organisation de
libération de la palestine est partie
pour moscou ce n'était évidemment pas un
hasard
les états arabes s'efforcent de faire
pression sur les états unis en
s'appuyant de plus en plus ouvertement
sur motion décidément les mirages
français se vendent bien à paris en ce
moment même au ministère de la défense
nationale le ministre des affaires
étrangères espagnol monsieur lopez bravo
et monsieur michel debré signent d'un
contrat la france va vendre 36 avions
mirage à l'espagne c'est le premier
résultat connu de la visite à paris de
monsieur lopez bravo qui va repartir
demain après une entrevue avec monsieur
georges pompidou et maintenant michel
drucker
nous allons aller à val gardena où comme
je disais tout à l'heure l'autrichien
karl france a remporté la médaille d'or
du slalom géant lui d'ailleurs c'est
d'ailleurs un triomphe ce matin à val
gardena des skieurs autrichiens qui
prennent la première et la seconde place
de ce slalom géant des championnats du
monde premier 32e blaye nerfs il était
déjà premier et deuxième
hier à l'issue de la première manche
d'ailleurs et c'est un hasard une
coïncidence troublante les trois
premiers de ce matin étaient les 30
premiers hier c'est à dire france blaye
nerfs et le suisse giovanoli jean noël
augert était à une seconde et 600e 2,36
hier on pensait qu'il pouvait obtenir
une place d'honneur ce matin
malheureusement le champion du monde de
slalom spécial est tombé nous allons
voir dans quelques instants les autres
français sont dépassés aussi du villaret
tomber bruxelles et peines prennent les
huitième et neuvième place mais voyons
le triomphe de change sans doute le plus
grand le champion de ces dix dernières
années qui a 32 ans encore dominé tous
ses adversaires
le voici qui débouche sur une piste très
longue 15 100 m beaucoup trop longue
d'ailleurs pour certains dont la
musculature des jambes souffrira
terriblement dans le dernier tiers du
parc
temps couvert température -7° france 32
ans je voulais dit hôtellier à 500
tonnes a dominé tout le monde il était
premier lieu hier à l'issue de la
première manche il a gagné ce matin car
c'est un garçon très à technique c'est
beaucoup d'expérience et ce sont les
hommes les plus résistants les plus
expérimentés qui ont gagné ce match
c'est le cas de france qui termine ici
son parcours sans se désunir
alors que la plupart des concurrents
subiront 7,5 parcours 2 4 4 pour 15
cents mètres de piste c'est le meilleur
temps je remporte donc la médaille d'or
ce n'est que justice
c'est un très grand champion qui
répétons le ce maintien au plus haut
niveau depuis douze ans c'est tout de
même assez exceptionnel france sera au
départ de la descente il en est le
favori vous le rappelle les espoirs
français reposent et sur les skis d'eau
gère à mi parcours le jeune français
était bien placé bon temps intermédiaire
mais regardez à quatre portes de la
voile à oger est fatigué il n'en peut
plus il avait terminé très éprouvé hier
et il va perdre un ski le stick gauche
encore quatre portes l'arrivée proche le
cas de chants secours au gers est
terminée voilà c'est dommage car oger
pouvait prétendre à une bonne place ce
matin à val gardena
les autres français je vous le répète on
était dépassé aussi du villaret tomber
les russes et les peines sont 8e et 9e
je vous redonne ce classement chb liner
giovanoli quatrième and allemands de
l'ouest rigueur ex-aequo avec un autre
autrichien avait fait un triomphe de
l'autriche quatre autrichiens dans les
cinq premiers échanges
c'est important va très certainement
prendre aujourd'hui la tête de la coupe
du monde de ski il va dépasser russell
ethnie en tout cas il apprendra
certainement dimanche car il est le
grand favori de la descente il a reporté
toutes les grandes descentes de cette
saison encore un mot pour vous dire que
les femmes disputent actuellement la
lande stop la descente a lieu demain et
que l'ordre des départs est connu olga
pâle championne olympique de la
spécialité partira première michel
jacquot deuxième françoise maquis 8e
florencio rire 10e et isabelle mir 11e
voilà guy tu laisses pour val gardena
je crois qu'on peut dire chapeau
monsieur prendre c'est vraiment un très
grand champ c'est un grand bonhomme est
je crois maintenant michel drucker que
nous allons parler automobile oui un
événement dans le domaine du sport
automobile les premiers tours de roue de
la monoplace britannique marks hier à
silverstone
stéphane colas
ou inutile de vous dire qu'elle était
attendue avec impatience cette première
apparition de la nouvelle formule 1
britannique march l'histoire quatre
hommes bien connus dans les milieux de
l'automobile robin air max mosley à la
nourrice et g cocker décide l'an dernier
d'entreprendre la construction d'une
voiture de formule jusqu'ici rien de
trop extraordinaire mais là où la sphère
devient plus insolite c'est quand on
apprend à la fin de l'année dernière que
quatre des plus grands noms du sport
automobile jackie stewart mario andretti
crée ses manèges aussi fortes ont choisi
de piloter en soixante dix sept voitures
dans la construction à l'époque n'est
même pas terminée une liste
impressionnante à laquelle s'ajoutent
bientôt les noms des deux grands espoirs
jeu ni cerveau gave à aironi peters a
avoué qu'il ya de quoi exciter la
curiosité si la voiture en effet n'avait
pas répondu aux espoirs mis en elle pour
ses premiers tours de roues seuls
circulent silverstone aux mains de chris
émanent d'abord puis de jakie quartz
c'est tout le championnat du monde 70
qui risquait d'être bouleversée mais les
champions avaient vu juste
la marche est apparue comme une voiture
certes extrêmement classique cas
classique mais efficace puisque chris
emon malgré les consignes de prudence
réussi à égaler le record du circuit à
plus de 200 km heure de moyenne avec une
telle brochette de pilotes marche risque
de faire une entrée fracassante dans le
monde de la formule 1 le 7 avril au le 7
mars par donc les au grand prix
d'afrique du sud
le metteur en scène italien michelangelo
antonioni a été arrêté cette nuit par
les policiers britanniques qu'il
arrivait de new york par avion et les
douaniers ont trouvé de la drogue du
haschich dans ses bagages
antonioni c'est l'auteur de la note et
de l'avventura ou souvenez peut-être
antonioni risque une amende de 3300
francs ou un an de prison
les policiers britanniques ont
d'ailleurs beaucoup de travail en ce
moment scotland yard a lancé une
opération de grande envergure la plus
grande dit on depuis la sphère du train
postal pour essayer enfin de retrouver
madame mc oui la seule information
véritablement nouvelles de plusieurs
monsieur alex mckay poudre de la
disparue a déclaré ne pas avoir eu
connaissance d'une correspondance
expliquant la prétendue confusion dans
les ravisseurs auraient été victimes à
savoir qu'il se soit trompé est enlevé
mme adam mckay à la place de madame
murdoch épouse du propriétaire du
journal dont monsieur mcc est
administrateur cette information est
issue des quotidiens londoniens scotland
yard ne se prononce pas sur ce coup
quoi qu'il en soit les recherches se
poursuivent dans une ferme isolée du
village de stocking pelham
officiellement la thèse de la mort de la
disparue n'est pas retenue viens nous
allons maintenant passer à la partie
magazine du journal
jeanine alexandre c'est à vous via des
transatlantiques ont tu leurs vols
malheureusement étant donné le peu de
temps dont on dispose pour voyager
maintenant et la rapidité les transports
les transatlantiques disparaît ce sont
désormais les uns après les autres
il leur reste toutefois une possibilité
une vocation les croisières mais ça
c'est pour très peu d'entre eux voici ce
qu'il advient des autres pendant 17 ans
le ss united states été l'un des plus
grand paquebot du monde et le plus
rapide 694 cabine théâtre trois salles à
manger qu'un 100 passagers son
exploitation a coûté 11 millions de
dollars au gouvernement américain et
malgré ce son déficit et 2 4 millions de
dollars
mais il n'ya plus de passagers à bord du
navire il est abandonné
il ne portera plus le pavillon américain
des mille hommes d'équipage il n'en
demeure plus que deux le capitaine est
un ingénieur qui chaque matin viennent
d'abord pour veiller sur ce navire de
400 millions de francs
le capitaine air dans les salles
désertent la tête pleine de souvenirs
les plus grands paquebots américains
partagent le destin ce navire sept
d'entre eux ont été vendus l'année
dernière la plupart des paquebots se
reconvertissent en effectuant les
croisières hivernal mais 90 % de ce
marché contrôlé par des compagnies ne
battant pas pavillon américain et sur
onze pack buanec un seul rapporte de
l'argent
viens nous allons aborder maintenant la
chronique juridique de christiane de la
croix c'est une rubrique qui suscite
toujours beaucoup de courrier et le
secrétariat de l'ordre des avocats est
un petit peu débordé c'est difficile de
répondre individuellement
c'est pourquoi au cours de cette
chronique nous allons traiter des sujets
qui intéressent le plus grand nombre
d'entre vous aujourd'hui le droit au
travail tous ceux et toutes celles qui
exercent un métier 11 sur le plan
professionnel des devoirs mais aussi des
droits des droits que bien souvent ils
ignorent qu'ils sont pourtant leur seul
moyen de défense
pour répondre à vos questions un avocat
à la cour de paris m voici d'abord le
cas d'une secrétaire qui a eu des
problèmes avec son enfant sont très
jeunes enfants qui est hospitalisée qui
a besoin de ces soins constants cette
personne peut-elle bénéficier d'un congé
spécial avec sun elle doit savoir tout
d'abord que l'employeur dans la plupart
des professionnels même pas obligé de
lui accorder un congé sans solde
au surplus la sécurité sociale n'a prévu
aucune prestation particulière pour
compenser la perte de salaire de la mer
qui s'absente pour soigner son enfant
malade bien plus est les seuls si elle
n'a pas un mari assuré social elle
perdra le bénéfice du régime général de
sécurité sociale puisqu'il n'ya plus
paiement de cotisations et elle devra
prendre la précaution de s'inscrire au
régime volontaire
elle devra donc faire très attention
avant de desceller pas que ce soit une
autre lettre vous savez que certains
enfants handicapés travaillent dans des
ateliers spéciaux et ils ont de faibles
rémunérations d'ailleurs et bien une
mère dont les enfants travaillent
peut-elle bénéficier d'allocations
familiales
les allocations familiales sont
accordées aux enfants handicapés jusqu'à
l'âge de 20 ans mais lorsqu'ils
travaillaient les parents perdent elles
bénéfice des allocations familiales
alors que ce travail faiblement
rémunérés faisait partie de la
rééducation de l'enfant aussi une
circulaire du 16 juin 1969 at elle prévu
le maintien de ces allocations
familiales si les ans par an demandent
préalablement l'autorisation d'une
commission spéciale qui s'appelle la
commission d'orientation des infirmes
autre chose il y a pas mal d'enfants qui
travaillent même pendant les vacances et
surtout pendant les vacances une mère
d'hôtel des cas déclarés les salaires
qu'ils ont perçues pour l'allocation
logement bien entendu car c'est le
salaire global de toute la famille qui
compte pour déterminer
le plafond de ressources au dessus
duquel on ne peut prétendre à
l'allocation de logement
si bien que les parents doivent faire
très attention s'ils sont dans un cas
limite ils peuvent perdre cette
allocation parce que leurs enfants à
travailler et à gagner ainsi en réalité
son argent de poche et une
téléspectatrice nous écrit son fils aîné
à l'étranger on lui a refusé
l'allocation maternité est ce normal
c'est absolument normal cette allocation
n'est donnée que pour les enfants nés en
france une personne qui bénéficient de
congés payés at elle le droit pendant la
durée de ces vacances de faire un
travail complémentaire absolument pas
c'est formellement interdit c'est du
travail noir les congés sont faits pour
que le salarié puisse se reposer
une dernière question si vous voulez
bien mettre peut-on faire une saisie
arrêt sur les allocations familiales du
tout sauf dans le cas des dettes
alimentaire de l'article deux endroits
du code civil c'est tout à fait
exceptionnel
je vous remercie m dit laisse une
dépêche vient de tomber
oui c'est encore une dépêche de val
d'isère propos de l'avalanche qui a
enlevé ce matin un chalet de l'union des
centres de montagne le commandement les
secours annonce qu'il y a maintenant 42
morts retirés des débris et identifiés
nous allons reprendre le cours de notre
magazine
nous allons voir la ville historique de
saumur elle supervise très sérieusement
la restauration de son quartier ancien
dont les plus vieilles maisons date du
15ème siècle c'est un reportage de notre
station du mans réalisé par jean charles
deniau image de marque flanc droit
certains quartiers de villes historiques
comme sarlat avignon bouge
uzès ont été déclarées secteur
sauvegardé par une loi de 1970 il en est
de même pour saumur où des travaux sont
entrepris pour restaurer une grande
partie du vieux quartier
quel est exactement l'étendue du secteur
sauvegardé de saumur c'est ce que nous
avons demandé à monsieur la maison
l'architecte chargé de la restauration à
le secteur sauvegardé de saumur séant
sur ie 30 hectares environ
conte depuis les coteaux de la loire
jusqu'au château en allant depuis les
hardes signé jusqu'au pont de saumur et
au point de vue historique quelle est
l'importance et bien c'est un quartier
extrêmement important au point des
histoires puisque toute l'histoire de
saumur s'est déroulée au pied du
taux nous trouvons des maisons depuis le
15e siècle jusqu'à nos jours on trouve
18 maison du xvème 26 du 16e 60 du xviie
300 du xviiie presqu'autant du 19ème et
très peu du 20e quelle est l'importance
des travaux qui vont être entrepris et
bien un premier secteur opérationnel
vient de se mettre en route
les travaux viennent de commencer et
c'est une zone qui s'étend sur trois
hectares autour de l'église saint-pierre
et de la grand rue
nous avons eu beaucoup de difficultés
avec le coteau de saumur le coteau
saumur effet en tuffeau cette roche se
délite petit à petit et nous voyons ce
coteau s'effondrer sur les maisons qui
se trouvent dosettes en contrebas et a
donc fallu faire une étude détaillée du
coteau pour savoir comment nous allions
pouvoir le remettre en état et empêcher
des accidents sur des maisons
extrêmement intéressante
certaines maisons sont encore habités
comment procédez-vous alors pour les
travaux eh bien nous nous visitons
chacun des propriétaires et nous
étudions maison par maison
comment le propriétaire envisage de
transformer sa maison quand les travaux
seront terminés
eh bien je suis optimiste je pense sept
ans mais je suis certain que dans dix
ans le choeur de saumur revivra
en
hitler quelles sont les dernières
dépêches en provenance de val d'isère
bien la dernière c'est celle d'andré
lecture tout à l'heure et qui annonçait
42 morts identifiés elle était
exactement date et de 13h15 il ya donc
une dizaine de minutes à peine je vous
rappelle que cette avalanche s'est
produite ce matin vers 8h alors dû à
l'heure du petit déjeuner alors que dans
un chalet hôtel
un groupe de 200 jeunes gens environ
étaient en train de prendre son petit
déjeuner l'avalanche qui est tombé du
haut de la montagne dit de solaise à
emporter toute la salle à manger c'était
de la neige poudreuse
contrairement à ce qui se produit avec
des avalanches en neige lourde
le chalet n'a pas été emporté la neige
poudreuse s'est infiltré à travers les
murs sous les fenêtres sous les portes
et elle a balayé ainsi la salle à manger
et la plupart des gens qui déjeunaient
ont été emportées projeté sur la route
sur d'autres maisons alentour les
immédiatement le plan orsec a été
déclenché les secours se sont organisés
mais ils sont très contrariée par un
mauvais temps le plafond est bas il
pleut il tombe de la neige fondue on ne
sait pas trop et la météo ne s'annonce
pas très bonne monsieur pompidou a
demandé au ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur raymond marcellin de se rendre
sur place pour organiser les sauvetages
tout ce que l'on sait pour l'instant
c'est que dans ce chalet se trouvait
donc 200 jeunes gens en majorité des
français mais un groupe d'une vingtaine
de jeunes belges et six allemands
étaient là aussi nous ne possédons pour
l'instant aucune précision sur
l'identité des 42 victimes merci
meatless nous allons maintenant
retrouver la bourse avoue gérard vidal
anges
aujourd'hui le marché est beaucoup plus
calme et transactions sont réduites et
les cours des valeurs françaises son jeu
également en baisse les écarts sont
toutefois assez modeste voyez il ya
beaucoup de monde à la bourse de paris
malgré tous les curieux et on peut
constater que du personnel féminin
maintenant travail dans les charges
d'agent de change
là les veines